SANDRA:  PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
FRIDAY ANNOUNCING THAT CHURCHES
AND OTHER HOUSES OF WORSHIP
SHOULD NO LONGER NEED TO ABIDE
BY THE SAME RESTRICTIONS THAT
HAVE FORCED BUSINESSES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO CLOSE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC.
>> SOME GOVERNORS HAVE DEEMED
LIQUOR STORES AND ABORTION
CLINICS AS ESSENTIAL.
BUT HAVE LEFT OUT CHURCHES AND
OTHER HOUSES OF WORSHIP.
IT’S NOT RIGHT.
SO I’M CORRECTING THIS INJUSTICE
AND CALLING HOUSES OF WORSHIP
ESSENTIAL.
I CALL UPON GOVERNORS TO ALLOW
OUR CHURCHES AND PLACES OF
WORSHIP TO OPEN RIGHT NOW.
SANDRA:  THE PRESIDENT ADDING
THAT IF GOVERNORS OF THOSE
STATES WON’T LET CHURCHES OPEN,
HE WILL OVERRIDE THEM.
THOUGH IT’S STILL NOT CLEAR IF
HE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
JOINING US NOW, HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY, ALEX AZAR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
HAPPY MEMORIAL DAY TO YOU.
>> SAME TO YOU GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU AND YOUR VIEWERS, THANKS.
SANDRA:  IT IS SUNDAY MORNING
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE WAKING UP WONDERING
IF IT’S SAFE TO RETURN TO THEIR
CHURCH OR THEIR PLACE OF WORSHIP
THIS MORNING.
YOU TELL THEM WHAT?
>> WELL, WE BELIEVE IT IS AS
LONG AS YOUR CHURCH IS TAKING
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS AND WE
PUT OUT GUIDANCE TO THAT EFFECT.
MY CHURCH BACK IN INDIANAPOLIS,
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY’VE GOT APPOINTMENTS.
YOU SIGN UP SO THEY DON’T GET
OVERCROWDED.
YOU GET SCREENED FOR TEMPERATURE
AS WELL AS SYMPTOMS AS YOU COME
IN.
YOU SOCIALLY DISTANCE AMONG
FAMILY UNITS IN THE CHURCH.
THE CHURCH HAS BEEN SANITIZED BY
THE CLEANING WORKERS THERE.
SO WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK, BACK
TO SCHOOL, AND BACK TO WORSHIP
IN SAFE WAYS BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S HISTORIC
RESPONSE HERE.
SANDRA:  SECRETARY AZAR, HAS
BEEN FASCINATING TO SEE SOME OF
THE ACCOMMODATION THAT’S
CHURCHES MADE EVEN DURING THE
SHUTDOWN, HOLDING ONLINE
SERVICES, DRIVE-UP SERVICES, ET
CETERA.
THE CDC GUIDELINES HAVE BEEN
RELEASED.
WE HAVE SOME OF THEM FOR YOU UP
ON THE SCREEN.
WHILE THEY ARE LENGTHY, WE CHOSE
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ONES.
OF COURSE, THAT IS MAKING AN
ADVERTISERS AND SOAPS --
SANITIZERS AND SOAPS HANDY,
WEARING CLOTH MASKS, SOCIAL
DISTANCING OF COURSE AND WHAT
STRUCK ME WAS LIMITING THE
SHARING OF BOOKS AND HYMNALS IN
PEWS AND SHARES.
YOU SEE THE SAME THING IN
RESTAURANTS WITH MENUS, THEY
HAVE ONE-TIME MENUS SO PEOPLE
AREN’T USING THE SAME THINGS IN
FRONT OF THEM.
THE WASHINGTON POST IS REPORTING
THE REASON FOR THE DAY LAY --
DELAY IN GUIDANCE FROM THE CDC
ON FAITH-BASED OPERATIONS
BECAUSE THERE WAS DISAGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE CDC AND THE WHITE
HOUSE.
ARE BOTH IN AGREEMENT ON THOSE
GUIDELINES, MR. SECRETARY?
>> YES, THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW, THERE’S AN IT ITERATIV
PROCESS THAT WE ENGAGE IN WITH
CDC, THE WHITE HOUSE AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE INTERAGENCY TO MAKE
SURE WHATEVER WE PUT OUT IS AS
GOOD AS POSSIBLE.
IT DOESN’T HELP A PRIEST,
PASTOR, IMAM, RABBI TO GET A 60
PAGE DOCUMENT THAT GOES THROUGH
EVERYTHING AS IF YOU HAVE A
MASTER’S IN EPIDEMIOLOGY.
WE PUT INFORMATION LIKE THAT OUT
ALSO.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE PUT
ACTIONABLE, UNDERSTANDABLE
INFORMATION OUT TO LEADERS OF
FAITH COMMUNITIES, ALSO OUR
SUMMER CAMP DIRECTORS, SCHOOL
LEADERS AND THOSE WHO RUN SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT’S JUST A PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
WE’RE FITTING OUR INFORMATION TO
OUR AUDIENCE.
SANDRA:  I WANT TO GET TO SUMMER
SCHOOL AND SCHOOL IN GENERAL IN
JUST A MOMENT AS WELL AS THOSE
SUMMER CAMPS.
FIRST, I WANT TO TAKE THIS BIG
PICTURE.
THE FDA COMMISSIONER, DR. HAHN
THIS MORNING, HE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AND HE ESSENTIALLY
SAID THIS VIRUS IS NOT CONTAINED
YET.
AND SO WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WILL BE
HEADING OUT TO ENJOY MEMORIAL
DAY SERVICES AND CELEBRATIONS,
IT IS UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL TO
YOU AS AN AMERICAN TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AND LIMIT THE SPREAD OF
THIS VIRUS.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE THIS
MORNING, MR. SECRETARY?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY I WOULD
ENDORSE WHAT DR. HAHN HAD TO SAY
THERE BUT I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT
THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
OUR GOVERNOR’S HISTORIC RESPONSE
TO THIS, WE HAVE TO AND WE CAN
GET BACK TO WORK, TO SCHOOL, TO
COMMUNITY, TO ENGAGEMENT,
BECAUSE IT’S NOT AN ISSUE OF
HEALTH VERSUS OUR ECONOMY.
IT’S ACTUALLY AN ISSUE OF HEALTH
VERSUS HEALTH.
BY BEING LOCKED UP IN OUR HOMES,
THERE’S VERY REAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES.
THE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISLOCATION LEADS TO SUICIDE AND
MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FEWER CANCER SCREENINGS AND
TREATMENTS GOING ON.
WE HAVE LESS PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES, MILLIONS OF KIDS
AREN’T GETTING PEDIATRIC
VACCINATIONS.
THOSE ARE REAL DISCERNABLE
IMMEDIATE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
THAT HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED JUST
AS MUCH AS THE SPREAD OF THIS
DEGREES EASE HAS -- DISEASE HAS
TO BE CONSIDERED.
SANDRA:  DR. FAUCI WHO ONCE SAID
AT A CAPITOL HILL HEARING THAT
HE IS ONLY LOOKING AT THE
SCIENCE AND THE MEDICAL SIDE OF
THINGS, HE IS NOW PUTTING OUT A
NEW WARNING AND A NEW INTERVIEW,
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON SHUTTING
DOWN AND STAYING SHUT DOWN FOR
TOO LONG.
I’LL THROW HIS WORDS UP ON THE
SCREEN.
HE SAID THIS.
WE CAN’T STAY LOCKED DOWN FOR
SUCH A CONSIDERABLE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT YOU MIGHT DO I
REPARABLE DAMAGE AND HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES, EVEN
CONSEQUENCES FOR HEALTH.
IS THIS PERHAPS A SIGN THAT
DR. FAUCI AND THE TASK FORCE
TEAM MIGHT BE SEEING THAT SOME
STATES ARE TAKING THE LOCKDOWN
AND SHUTDOWN ORDERS TOO FAR,
SECRETARY SAY GLAIR?
>>AZAR.>> THE PERSPECTIVE IS VE
WISE.
IT TAKES BALANCE.
WE TOOK THE MEASURES OF SHUTDOWN
BECAUSE UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THOSE WERE THE RIGHT MEASURES TO
RECOMMEND.
NOW THAT WE HAVE ONE OF THE
WORLD’S BEST TESTING SYSTEMS,
MORE TESTING GOING ON THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD, NOW
THAT WE HAVE THE STATES IN THE
DRIVER’S SEAT WITH CONTACT
TRACING SETTING AND ISOLATION OF
CASES AND SEEKING OUT AND
CONTAINING VARIOUS OUTBREAKS, WE
HAVE THE TOMBS TOOLS TO GET BACK
AND RUNNING AGAIN IN A SAFE,
SMART WAY AND WE JUST CAN’T STAY
LOCKED DOWN FOREVER AS DR. FAUCI
SAID.
SANDRA:  WE HEAR YOU.
I KNOW THERE’S MANY AMERICANS
WHO FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT THAT
WHILE WANTING TO STILL BE SAFE
AND STOP THE SPREAD OF OF THE
VIRUS.
THAT BEING SAID, WE HEARD A LOT
OF THAT FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
IN A NEW INTERVIEW, SPEAKING TO
MARIA BARTIROMO THIS WEEK, HE
NOT ONLY SOUNDS THE ALARM ABOUT
STAYING CLOSED TOO LONG, BUT HE
ALSO STARTS TO POINT FINGERS AND
SAYS THERE’S POLITICS AT PLAY
HERE.
HERE’S THE PRESIDENT.
>> MARIA: YOUR CRITICS WANT YOU
TO KEEP IT CLOSED GOING INTO THE
ELECTION.
>> YEAH, I DO, I THINK IT’S A
POLITICAL THING IN ADDITION.
I THINK SOME --
>> MARIA: THEY’RE SAYING YOU’RE
PUTTING MONEY, BUSINESS AHEAD OF
LIVES.
>> NO, NO.
I THINK THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
SEE THE RIGHT THING HAPPEN, THEY
AGREE WITH ME.
WE HAVE TO GET OUR COUNTRY OPEN.
SANDRA:  SECRETARY AZAR, ARE
POLITICS AT PLAY?
AND HAVE POLITICS PLAYED ANY
PART, IMPEDING YOUR ABILITY TO
KEEP THE COUNTRY SAFE?
>> I DON’T WANT TO GET INTO ANY
TYPE OF POLITICS DISCUSSION.
I JUST HAD THE PLEASURE OF
TRAVELING ON COMMERCIAL AIRLINE
TO NORTH CAROLINA AND FLORIDA
THIS WEEK, NORTH CAROLINA LED BY
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR COOPER AND
FLORIDA LED BY REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR DE SANTIS.
WE’RE SEEING REOPENING IN SAFE
WAYS.
THE COCA-COLA 600 RUNNING TODAY,
I SAW THE PRECAUTIONS THEY’RE
TAKING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
I GOT TO BE IN FLORIDA AT THE
MAYO CLINIC, SEE HOW THEY’RE
REOPENING TO GET ELECTIVE
PROCEDURES UP AND RUNNING AND DO
PREVENTATIVE CARE AND MAKE SURE
PEOPLE GET THE HEALTHCARE THEY
NEED.
I THINK IT’S GREAT TO SEE HOW
WE’RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
GOVERNORS, HELPING TO BRING THE
COUNTRY BACK AGAIN.
SANDRA:  FINAL THOUGHT?
YOU ASK PARENTS ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY, THEY’RE WONDERING ABOUT
SUMMER CAMPS, WONDERING ABOUT
SUMMER SCHOOL AND WONDERING
ABOUT KIDS RETURNING TO SCHOOL
IN THE FALL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT WHERE
YOU STAND ON WHETHER OR NOT
THAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> WELL, FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WOULD SAY THAT ANY PARENT JUDGE
YOUR INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES
FIRST.
ARE YOU, YOUR CHILD OR OTHER
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE OR AT RISK.
YOU’VE ALWAYS GOT TO LOOK TO
PROTECT YOUR HOUSEHOLD UNIT
FIRST IN MAKING THESE DECISIONS.
THEN I’D SAY FOLLOW THE GUIDANCE
OF YOUR LOCAL LEADERS.
THIS IS A LOCALLY LED, STATE
SUPERVISED FEDERALLY SUPPORTED.
WE PUT OUT GUIDANCE ABOUT
SCHOOLS AND SUMMER CAMPS GETTING
REOPENED AND SAFE PROCEDURES TO
DO SO.
AS ALWAYS, YOUR LOCAL AND STATE
LEADERS KNOW THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ON THE GROUND BEST.
FOLLOW THEIR GUIDANCE.
BUT I HOPE THAT WE’LL BE BACK AT
SUMMER CAMP.
I HOPE WE’LL BE BACK AT SCHOOL.
AGAIN, THERE ARE WAYS TO DO IT
SAFELY WE DON’T HAVE TO BE IN
OUR HOUSE TOSS BE SAFE.
WE CAN DO THIS SAFELY.
SANDRA:  WITH THE FEW SECONDS I
HAVE LEFT, AS FAR AS A VACCINE,
YOU AND I SPOKE EARLIER THIS
WEEK ABOUT THAT.
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC AS THE WHITE
HOUSE IS THAT WE COULD SEE ONE
BY END OF YEAR?
>> THIS IS A VERY CREDIBLE
OBJECTIVE.
WE JUST SIGNED A DEAL WITH
ASTRAZENECA FOR THE OXFORD
VACCINE, WHERE BY OCTOBER COULD
HAVE 100 MILLION DOSES OF
VACCINE AND 300 MILLION DOSES BY
EARLY NEXT YEAR.
WE’RE GOING TO PLACE MULTIPLE
BETS LIKE THIS AND DRIVE
OPERATION WARP SPEED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE DEMANDS
THAT WE REDUCE INEFFICIENCY IN
THAT SYSTEM WHEN WE GET THESE
KIND OF RESULTS IF AT ALL